haha afraid are you starting out and I'm
not in my car I'm in a place with this
human huh it's Brizzy voices you don't
know whose voice is this you're an idiot
you should go over to her Channel and
check it out and we just shot two videos
and they're super super fun and we're
also shooting I mean that tin foil that
Tim boiled oh oh we're shooting in the
big frame offices on a weekend where
there's no one here look at all these
sets this whole thing and it's like this
is like an adult adventure daydream or
you're like I always wonder what it'd be
like to be the only person in an office
let's crash the mystery guitar man
where's mr. guitar mate said oh we're
going yes no idea it's dark but whoa
look at all of these things I won't show
any secrets but there's a bathroom he's
so lucky
oh my god hello oh you are gross okay
it's just like wait your face before you
talk to me
good morning it's Monday and I'm headed
to a shoot for Smosh which is really fun
because I've never officially met Smosh
before like you've been in the same room
but we've never officially met each
other the bad thing is I woke up a
half-hour pass my call time because my
alarm never went off so I'm already 40
minutes late so really great first
impression your feel like you're coated
in a fine layer of
and then everything is for all the dogs
there's a dog statue
okay see that where's my hands right
there I'm so nervous
and I'm really excited
water running making him yes okay I just
got on the dog training session of goose
and oh I missed there's so much was just
doing a lot better and just stay there
and get more training and that's fine
because I have a lot of travel that I'm
doing but Oh fine doing that oh Jesus
okay I'm inside the village is a factory
with
really cool guys
I hope I have things in my teeth that
are distracting okay I just got done
running a ton of errands with Hannah I
had to do a bunch of shopping because
tomorrow I'm going to France I told you
this so I don't know I forget I'm sorry
if I didn't tell you I'm going for our
YouTube thing for a few days and while
I'm in France I will be announcing a
really cool project that memory and I
are working on and I can't announce it
yet another three time oh so now I'm
headed to just get as much stuff done
tonight as I can before I leave because
there's a lot of stuff to be done and
then I go to France and Mail cbq
[ __ ] a bellpull wasps a [ __ ] pile on
Glee that's all I can do
I don't even know how to say I don't
know someone tell me how do I say it in
French how do I say it in France French
but I I supposed to do so much stuff and
then I got hijacked and I all braided my
hair and I cut my bangs I'm a
professional now I will edit this video
once I play with all the new makeup I
got today I don't know